this is deceiving like the soda that
Chuck is drinking right now is he
drinking soda again you know yeah sure
he it's not di Coke it's not Diet Coke
when I was thinking that I I don't know
if they had me on tape I was like
something going on here what is that
somebody mess with my D coat he did then
obviously he
know you know he did
it watch his face
America one two
something ain't
[Laughter]
right give us that give us give us the
taste test looked at my I looked at
my I was like I said give us that taste
test mouth again
yeah that ain't it that ain't it that
ain't my I paid attention I knew it was
something wrong when I got my diet coke
American Express teammates if you would
please as we take a look at the Toronto
Raptors New Look Toronto Raptors after
the trade of Pascal seak the only guy
Chris bu is the only guy left from that
2019 championship team Scotty Barnes got
13 RJ Barrett does two Bruce Brown in
his debut has played 8 minutes in the
first half quickly has been playing well
for uh for Toronto since that trade as
has RJ Barrett but uh now it's it's
Scotty Barnes as it's Scotty Barnes but
I'm not going to go to the board today
because I have a story want to talk and
I want to have Shaq finish it up for me
we you know I heard uh gr Hill and Vince
Carter talking about when I used to give
nicknames when I first got here the
Matrix was sha Maran halfman half
amazing I gave homage actually the
there's a real halfman half amazing from
street ball that I took that name from
and gave it to Vince Carter from nas Nas
line but Shaq was telling me how he got
the name Superman and why he thought a
Superman how did you come up with the
name Superman you'll be really
interested to hear this Chuck
so it was the first movie I've ever seen
in my life and one of the scenes in
Superman was where he beat the train so
he have to cross the train tracks every
day to go to school so one day the train
was way back there so I just started
running so he said he be a train just
run I beat a train in my mind I beat the
train he said no he said in his mind
back there he didn't say that Ernie he
said I beat a train and that's when I
knew I was super bad I was like wait we
got to say he beat need a train in a
race New Jersey yeah I seen the train
coming and I waited then I just took off
boom and then I was flying I look back I
was like damn I'm Superman that's how
that's how he became faster than a
speeding bullet more powerful than a
locomotive I wish the train how to hit
him that would have been great so so
that story replaces what Toronto is
doing with Scotty Barnes without
question because we we don't even know
yet what they're doing they got some
more trades to make you know but I just
was amazed that this mag be the train
well and
I'm we need to fire the train driver not
hit his ass I'm just you know Toronto
got a I think Messiah Jerry Sam prey
they're arguably the two best gyms in
the NBA msai does a fantastic all their
players can play a guy in Denver what's
his name oh Calvin boo Calvin boo is but
yeah he did a fabulous job add pieces
OKC OKC that sound
prey but I didn't hear you say sam cuz
you're all over the damn place well cuz
I was talking about something come on
Superman Superman we had about 15
seconds come on let me take you to the
ghetto tonight let's see if you can out
run a damn train tonight you old ass you
going to just going to leave that there
come okay good come on let's see if you
can run a train tonight
good if you can finish a thought tonight
chucker that'd be hey that's my man bich
right there that ain't my mama cooking
that ain't my mama
cooking man
that's great right there Damon
718 let's see it's worth it's worth
another look that Ain my mama
cooking what what did you put in my cup
what did you put in my cup in your
cup